hello everyone and welcome to Abby's
kitchen I forget how I even do my
introduction anymore
Passover actually commemorates the
Israelites what's that word liberation
liberation liberation alright let's try
this the Israelites why can't I get that
word liberation so God told Moses to
tell the Israelites nope that's wrong
the liberation pass over their homes and
NC and not sentinel state save them from
his fury we got all the things you got a
dirty for you gotta go to where you got
off grain free you got paleo it's
Passover in Abby's house okay hey
everyone I'm a t-shirt welcome to Abby's
kitchen today we're going to be
commemorating the eight days of Passover
or seven days if you live in the Holy
Land of Israel now if you're not
familiar Passover commemorates the
liberation of the Israelites from
Egyptian slavery so as the story goes in
our Hebrew Bible or our Torah Moses
actually told the Egyptian the evil
Egyptian leader Pharaoh to let the
Israelites go but he refused multiple
times so God decided he was gonna smite
the Egyptian people with ten terrible
plagues we're talking about locusts and
frogs and hail and boils the stuff you
really don't want to get yourself into
so what he did was God decided to tell
Moses to tell the Israelites to mark
their homes so that he would pass over
those homes when all of these terrible
plagues were coming down so as the
Israelites were escaping they had to
rush out of there in such a hurry but
they didn't have time for their bread to
rise hence why we eat unleavened bread
during Passover also known as matzah now
here's the truth Mott's is not so great
doesn't have a whole lot of flavor
there's not much going on there in my
opinion but these desserts are totally
going to make up for them so today we're
going to be making some cherry chocolate
almond meringue cookie sandwiches such a
mouthful but so delicious
they are grain free gluten free and
dairy free and the perfect ending to any
Passover Seder or really any time of
year because they're just that good so
let's do this to a stand mixer I add
some egg whites lemon juice and a pinch
of salt and beat it on high until frothy
continue to be while adding superfine
sugar one spoonful at a time eventually
it'll reach stiff peak form you know it
basically will look like the head of a
really funny bird finally I'll beat in
some artificial vanilla and some
maraschino cherry juice and then gently
fold in some sliced almonds next I add
some generous dollops onto the baking
sheet lined with a Silpat and I bake
them off at 250 degrees for about 40
minutes until lightly browned next I
melt some dairy-free dark chocolate over
a double boiler until super smooth and
then I set aside about a quarter cup
then I just add the rest to a cleaned
out stand mixer along with some thick
coconut cream and whip the whole thing
together until it reaches a mousse-like
consistency finally pipe a little of the
mousse onto the bottom of one of the
meringues and then add another one to
make a sandwich drizzle the cookies with
the remaining chocolate and then try
your best if it the whole thing in your
mouth at once enjoy alright here's a
little insider tip if you were just
going to your first passover seder sneak
a few of these beforehand because let's
be real the stator can be long and we
can get hand cream so I hope you enjoyed
this video if you did be sure to give it
a thumbs up leave me a comment below
with some of your go-to pass of her
friendly desserts subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]